[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANKUR KOTWAL: One of the
biggest challenges game
developers face is building
engaging game worlds.
We want to provide a
realistic environment that
isn't handcrafted, a
world that's familiar,
yet is fun for players,
regardless of where they are.
The Google Maps APIs gaming
offering solves this problem.
This platform for
building real world games
is built on Google
Maps and backed
by Google infrastructure.
Hi.
I'm Ankur Kotwal, a
developer advocate.
With the Google Maps
APIs gaming offering,
developers can create dynamic
experiences at global scale.
Google Maps APIs
provide hundreds
of millions of 3D buildings,
points of interest,
roads, landmarks,
cafes, parks, and more
to help you form
your game world.
This is the same model of
the world as Google Maps,
but you don't have to
be a mapping specialist
to build real world games.
The SDK interprets
the geo data for you.
Additionally, you can completely
customize your game world.
You can change colors,
apply alternate textures,
and even swap out
prefabs altogether.
The gaming offering
also enables you
to design rich and engaging
games in the real world.
You can ensure that players
have an engaging experience,
regardless of whether
they're in a busy urban city
or in a rural town.
Finally, you can also
deliver game experiences
at global scale.
Relying on Google's
infrastructure
means faster response
times, on-demand scaling,
and peace of mind.
Let's look at the
three components that
make up the gaming offering.
The first is access
to Google Maps data.
This is a rich, accurate, and
living model of the real world.
Since it's powered by the same
infrastructure as Google Maps,
it scales to billions
of daily requests
and is constantly
updated to reflect
our ever-changing world.
The second component
is an SDK for Unity.
The Maps Unity SDK
creates every Maps feature
as standard Unity game objects.
Since they're just standard
Unity game objects,
you can also add colliders
for physics and ray casting.
Each of these real
world features
comes with semantic metadata,
so you can correlate them
with your game.
You can fill parks with
trees, style your game world
in a fantasy land, or
use a specific 3D model
for each hospital in the city.
We include lots
of other features
to help you build your game such
as nine slicing for applying
textures to arbitrarily
sized buildings,
decorators for adding
parapets and other geometry
to the tops of
buildings, or borders
to simulate ambient
occlusion contact shadows.
We provide access to the
names of roads and buildings
and integrate with Unity's
lighting and skybox systems
for a beautiful day
and night cycle.
We also support Unity's
level of detail system,
automatically fading
out distant geometry
to maximize mobile performance.
The Maps Unity
SDK has been built
to be performant
on mobile devices,
yet it can scale up to the
most powerful gaming platforms.
The third and critical component
is the playable locations API,
which helps you design
interactions around real world
locations at global scale.
The playable locations API
provides more than just points
in space.
It provides
appropriate locations
that deliver an
engaging experience,
regardless of where
your players are.
The playable
locations API enables
you to tailor your gameplay
to natural environments,
like parks or rivers.
For example, you could
put treasure chests
at real world ATMs or
supplies at supermarkets.
You could also put more
valuable game rewards
at rarely visited locations.
To learn more, visit this
link and complete the form
to get in touch with us.
With the Google Maps
APIs gaming offering
you can make the real
world your playground.
[MUSIC PLAYING]